Enter LibGDX.
LibGDX is a Java game engine
an application framework
that makes making games so much easier.
It provides a bunch of useful
functionality, including great
drawing APIs, sound and asset handling,
user input management and
a ton of other features that
make writing a game super fast.
LibGDX does one better though.
Games written for LibGDX can be
deployed on Android, IOS, browsers,
and anywhere else the Java runs,
like your desktop computer.
So, let's check out how LibGDX works.
Up at the top of the stack here, here's
your game, and then here is LibGDX.
LibGDX provides a bunch of functionality
related to calling into your game when
it's time to do stuff.
But it also provides all of these
libraries for drawing, sound, storage,
networking, a bunch of other stuff.
So when your game needs
to draw something,
you call into LibGDX to ask it
to go draw something for you.
Now whenever you call a library
to go do some drawing for
you, that library doesn't
actually do the drawing itself.
It delegates that task to the underlying
hardware it's running on.
So, either that it talks to
the video card driver directly, or
it talks to some other abstraction
offered by the host operating system.
So here's the trick.
When LibGDX receives a request to
go draw something, it can go and
dispatch that command to an Android
system it's running on, but
it also knows how to tell if it's
running on iOS instead of Android.
It will dispatch a different
set of drawing commands to iOS.
Or LibGDX has an HTML backend, where
when your game requests some networking
to be done, LibGDX Intel,
I'm running as a web app this time.
I'm going to go do my networking using
a different set of commands than I would
if I was on Android or iOS.
And LibGDX has a background that
runs on desktop computers as well.
So, the APIs that your game uses, look
identical to you, regardless of whether
your game is running on Android, iOS, as
a web app, or on your desktop computer.
That means you only need
to write your game once and
LibGDX will allow it to run anywhere.